So in terms of optimization approaches, we
actually just looked at a couple of different
ideas. We, we just looked at generate and test, this sort of idea that you can
just run through all the different values in
the input space and see which one gives
the maximum. When is that a good idea and when is that not a good idea?
>> Well, it's probably a really good idea when you have
just a small set of things you need to generate and test.
>> Yeah, it really does require that we
have a small input space. And it's also particularly
helpful if it's a complex function, right?
Because there really isn't any other choice if
the function has kind of crazy behavior, like in the mod example that I gave.
Alright, for things like calculus, like, just
solving for what the optimum is analytically. When,
when is that a good idea and when is that not such a good idea?
>> Well, it's a good idea when you have a function where you
can do that. Where, there, well, first off, it has to have a derivative.
>> Right, and so, it seems like,
well, how are you going to write down a function that doesn't
have a derivative. Well for the thing we're trying to optimize is
some kind of, it could be, crazy because we defined it to be
crazy. We can define it with little, you know, like, ifs and
things like that, to make it only piecewise continuous. Or it
might be the, the, the thing we're optimizing is some process in
the real world that we just don't have a functional representation of.
All we can do is evaluate the fitness value at different inputs.
>> Right, or if the inputs are discrete.
>> Right, like in the first example, right. So it might not actually give us
any feedback if the derivative is, is, if
we're not moving in a smooth continuous space.
>> Hey is mod, does mod have a derivative.
>> Almost everywhere.
>> Just not everywhere.
>> Yeah. There's that, you know, because mod kind looks like ner, ner, ner,
ner. So it has this nice derivative
everywhere except for at these, at the jumps.
>> Which happen pretty often.
>> Yeah, there's a lot of them. But they're, you know, measure zero.
>> Okay.
>> Like, if you just picked a random number, it
wouldn't be at the jump. So it's not only important that
the function has a derivative, but the derivative, we need
to be able to solve it, solve that derivative equal to
zero. Newton's method can be helpful even outside of that
case, where we have a derivative, and we have time to
kind of iteratively improve, right? Just keep querying the the
function. Creeping up on what the optimum turns out to be.
So, okay, but then what do we do if these, these assumptions don't hold? So
we have a real, what would that mean? It would mean, what, big input space.
>> Still have a complex function.
>> Complex function.
>> No derivative, or difficult to find derivative.
>> I knew I had that derivative around here someplace.
>> [LAUGH] You know it's always the last place you find it.
>> [LAUGH] Indeed. Yeah. Exactly. And, and
actually I, I, I should have mentioned
one more thing about Newton's method. Which
is that the function has a derivative you
iteratively improve. And it really wants you to
have just a single optimum, because even Newton's
method can get stuck if it's in a situation where you have a, a curve say
like, like that. because Newton's method is just
going to hone in on the, the local peak.
>> So that would be bad if you have lots
of local maxima in this case, or optima in this case.
>> Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. So, so that's, you can list this as well,
possibly many local optima, right. The, the, the function has a kind of a
peak. That things around the peak are less than the peak but that
peak itself may be less than some other peak somewhere else in the space.
>> Makes sense.
>> So, as you might expect that our answer to this hard
question is going to be randomized optimization. The topic of today's lecture.